NARRATOR: In 1968, a
charismatic young musician
started a hippie commune
in the California desert.
His followers embraced
his message of sex,
drugs, racism, and murder.
That man was Charles Manson,
and he and his family
would become the face of
evil for the latter half
of the 20th century.
1969.
On August 9th and 10th, a
series of shocking murders
sent panic throughout
Los Angeles.
Seven people were
brutally killed,
including actress Sharon Tate,
who was eight months pregnant.
Their bodies were found in their
homes stabbed multiple times
and arranged in a
ritualistic manner.
Words were written on surfaces
in blood across the walls,
including pig, death
to pigs, and rise.
The case remained a
mystery for months
until Susan Atkins, a young
woman imprisoned on theft
charges, bragged
to a fellow inmate
about committing the
murders along with members
of her hippie cult. Atkins
claimed the cult was made up
of mostly women,
but their leader
was a diminutive Svengali
type named Charles Manson.
As the case against Manson
and his followers unfolded,
investigators learned
how he exploited
the Cultural
Revolution of the '60s
to orchestrate
unspeakable violence.
For young women
like Susan Atkins,
the hippie culture filled
with music, psychedelic drugs,
and free love was
a way to reject
their straight-laced
middle class upbringings
and find spiritual
enlightenment.
Charles Manson
used the lifestyle
to lure these impressionable
young women to his commune.
An uneducated ex-con, Manson
was nevertheless highly
intelligent and charismatic.
He preyed on the weaknesses
of his followers,
charming them with
flattery and then
breaking them down emotionally.
He brainwashed them with
habitual acid trips,
group sex, and rambling,
repetitive religious lectures.
A self-proclaimed
messiah, Manson preached
about an imminent race war,
naming it Helter Skelter
after the Beatles song
whose lyrics he believed
outlined the prophecy.
To ignite the war, he ordered
five of his family members
to break into the homes of
prominent people in Hollywood
and kill them as
gruesomely as possible.
They were instructed to
frame the Black Panthers
for the murders, writing
pig on the walls in blood
as a reference to
the term the Panthers
often used for policemen.
After Manson was
arrested, his followers
remained loyal, camping
outside the courthouse
as he awaited trial.
His co-defendants,
facing the death penalty,
carved x's into their
foreheads, cut off their hair,
and often disrupted
court proceedings
with taunts and outbursts.
After several months on
trial, all were found guilty
and later sentenced to death.
But their sentences would be
commuted to life in prison
when California invalidated
the death penalty in 1972.
It would take years for
many of Manson's followers
to recuperate from the
emotional manipulation and mind
control that contributed
to their horrific acts
of senseless violence.
The Manson murders hastened the
decline of the hippie movement,
forever tarnishing the peace
and love message of the '60s
by validating
America's worst fears
about drugs, sex,
and communal living.